el Papa Francisco dijo que este
peregrinaje de paz es una oportunidad
para cambiar el rumbo de este país qué
tanto peso tiene la presencia del papa
de El arzobispo de canterbury y del
moderador de la iglesia de Escocia en
esta nación
bueno es una novedad muy importante que
convivan y ejecuten Esta visita Pastoral
tres líderes cristianos de tres
confesiones importantes en Sudán del sur
pero tanto la tradiciones anglicanas o
escocesas como también el catolicismo
debido a que los componentes de las
disputas en Sudán del sur tienen rasgos
étnicos pero también religiosos en
primer lugar la disputa con ciudadanos
del Norte No De donde se independizó
Sudán del sur era una disputa entre un
Norte musulmán islámico y ulsur
Cristiano y dentro del mundo del Sudán
del sur también distintas facciones
tribales y distintas dificultades para
poder Establecer un estado en forma
luego de la independencia este proceso
requiere
consensos muy importantes entre un
gobierno que se define de unidad
nacional entre un vicepresidente que es
opositora a su vez al pero que conviven
en un gabinete conjunto la unidad por lo
tanto requiere un clima que va más allá
de lo político requiere un consenso
moral Por decirlo así para poder
consensuar una meta de construcción de
estado pensemos que Sudán del sur es el
país más joven del planeta el último en
lograr su independencia y por lo tanto
están todos los embriones de un estado
todavía naciendo no existe propiamente
tal un estado en forma y el factor
religioso puede ser tanto un factor que
coade a la unidad de de Sudán del sur
como también a su división
la cohesión política por lo tanto viene
a ser el mensaje del Papa Francisco
bueno en términos generales ya Usted lo
ha estado mencionando qué tanto peso
tiene la Iglesia Católica en Sudán del
sur
yo creo que junto con la Iglesia
Católica convive con una mayoría que es
más bien protestante está representada
en la visita de
Justin bieberly que es el el arzobispo
Carter y el moderador de la iglesia de
Escocia por la herencia británica dentro
de esa zona pero también el catolicismo
es importante en demográficamente las
tres confesiones vienen a ser las
mayoritarias dentro de ese país y a su
vez la identidad misma de Sudán del sur
se constituye a partir de la diferencia
con el norte en su adhesión al
cristianismo por lo tanto es
importantísima la presencia del Papa
para poder consolidar la identidad de
este estado naciente y la posibilidad de
ser viable en el futuro Bueno Este es el
quinto viaje del Papa a África y se da
en medio de la guerra en Ucrania un
conflicto que centra prácticamente toda
la atención internacional que el papa
visite democrática del Congo y Sudán del
sur puede llamar la atención del mundo o
su objetivo es ser una especie de
mediador entre las partes en conflicto
ambas cosas en primer lugar colocar el
acento en Las Guerras olvidadas guerras
como las que asolan al Congo o a la que
la que vive por tanto tiempo Ciudad del
sur u otras zonas de África están fuera
de la agenda noticiosa internacional
fuera de la visión de Los grandes de las
grandes potencias y muchas veces quedan
liberadas a los señores de la guerra a
los traficantes de armas a las disputas
de sanguinaria por lo tanto es muy
relevante este proceso